Donald Trump continues to threaten to
skip the first debate it will be on Fox
news on August 23rd this is a Republican
primary debate Donald Trump is citing a
bunch of different reasons for why he
might skip it this includes why would I
go I'm winning by so much not a very
good reason second Fox News is doing it
and Fox News hasn't exactly been good to
me it's unfair it's biased or whatever
the case may be and there's a third
reason Trump may want to skip the debate
which he's not saying which is that
Chris Christie one of his primary and
most forceful antagonists so far this
year Chris Christie has now qualified
for that debate because he's obtained
enough polling support and enough
individual donors to meet the
requirements to participate in that
debate so I I'll have to tell you I want
Trump there they should all debate he's
clearly scared if he doesn't go I'm with
you 100 I also understand why he would
be scared